well hey everybody my name is mike
vaultos and welcome to this presentation
on wonderful trading made easy
and you know these uh these markets
nowadays are
very uh all over the place you know
today
you know market made a new high and then
about an hour ago we started selling off
and making new loads you know we're down
about
just uh just over half a percent now
and you know order flow is a great tool
for traders to understand
what's happening in the market as it's
happening you know it's one thing to
look at a chart
after the fact and you know say oh i
would have bought here i was sold here
yet with the order flow you know it
gives you that advantage that you can
actually
see what's developing as in the market
as it's developing
so what you're going to learn today is
how to
easily read and understand order flow
how to turn order flow into a useful
tool
to make informed trades and how to use
order flow
to see when the big money is getting
active in the market
now for those that are new to one of my
presentations my name is michael voskos
i'm the founder
and trader at orderprobe.com but prior
to that
i spent eight years at jp morgan i was
vice president of futures trading
and you know this was a trading job you
know it wasn't a job where i was sitting
in an office looking at spreadsheets
and seeing which trader was you know
trading too much and go over and tap
on the shoulder no i was there banging
away at the computer you know i'd come
in
at six in the morning i was basically in
as far as i
started coming at six in the morning
when the electronic session would reopen
evening in the u.s and i would be there
until about 5 p.m
in the evening which is you know
running into mid-morning in europe
prior to that i spent four years at
cargill cargill's a big commodity
trading firm
and i was trading desk manager there we
traded every
imaginable commodity contract that you
can think
of you know from rapeseed palm oil
crude oil you know sunflower seeds even
you know black seaweed
everything it was tradable we traded it
prior to that i spent three years at
commerce bank in chicago
i was one of only a handful of traders
in the u.s at that time
back in the 90s that was actually
licensed to trade
on europe you know we can trade
the year the buns the bobble the shaft
in chicago you know one urex
went for electronic you know they
started giving terminals to
the banks and trading firms but then you
know the chicago board of trade
trade says hey you can't have
you know these foreign entities coming
into our ground
but fortunately you know i had a license
a ux license that was granted by
government so i was one of only a
handful of people that could play
direct at that time in the u.s and prior
to that spent a couple years at edf man
also a big commodity trading company on
a global macro trading desk
and i spent three years at dean witter
i started on the cme trading floor as a
runner literally
the bottom rung of the totem
bottom rung of the industry you know
that's how you got started back then you
know back in the 90s when we still had
trading floors
you know it was a great time you know if
you wanted to get involved
in the futures industry in the trading
industry you can go down and get a job
you know you could literally find
someone that worked on the exchange ask
if they knew anybody was hiring usually
within a day you could get a job
so what i'm talking about today is what
i've learned over these 25 years
of actual real-time trading experience
you know not just trading for myself but
trading for firms
you know this is what i did for a living
this is how i
paid for my car pay for my house paid
for everything
you know i actually traded you know it's
not like i was um all right
i was just trading on the side while
working full-time job no my job was
trading
and everything that i've learned with
regards to trading with regards to order
flow
is what i'm teaching you today
okay now in 2013 i left j.p morgan
because i wanted to spend more time with
my family
you know and trade for myself i got
tired of working
you know being in the office 11 hours a
day
you know you added travel to and from
the office i was literally spending half
my day
outside of the house you know the
trade-off between you know family life
and work life
it was work life was sucking everything
out of my life and i
said i can't do this anymore i know how
to train i'm going to trade for myself
and eventually you know i thought i
should write a book i learned a lot i
want to give back
and i'm going to give you a copy of my
book
you have to get the actual heart solver
you're going to get a link where you can
download it from
okay so it's 150 page book on order for
i talk a lot about
you know some of the experiences that
i've gone through you know and you know
how to
apply order flow to the market and you
stick around to the end
again you have to get a copy of that
book now
since 2013 i started trading for myself
you know i was using an order flow
software right because you know
it's different when you work in a bank
in a big trading firm because
the amount of data that you have is
unsurpassed
right banks and commodity firms they
just
spend money like a drunken sailor on the
latest technology
but as soon as i left the door you know
i'm training for myself
i had to find the right software right
and
i looked at a lot of different software
you know i i was even still using
bloomberg
i cost about two and a half thousand
dollars a month
and i had a order flow software to help
read the order flow but
it was just a basic software and i
wanted
the software to do more for me right
because that's what software is supposed
to do it's supposed to make your life
easier okay so you know the volume
footprint chart
was a big step forward in reading order
flow but then
you know there's certain things i'm
always looking for in the order flow
that you know i need to have this
in the software so that it can sort of
lift some of that heavy load off me
you know so it'll make my analysis a lot
quicker and a lot
faster and i met up with a programmer
who had already programmed
a volume footprint chart and i said hey
you know this is these are a lot of the
things i'm looking at in the order flow
put them
into the volume footprint chart so it'll
automatically appear
when the conditions are met and you know
the program for ninjatrader 8 you know
we i put it on ninjatrader 8.
and hence the order flows trader 2.0 for
mediatrader 8 was born it's a volume
footprint chart with
seven pre-programmed order flow
indicators and the reason i talk about
that is because
charts that are used in this
presentation are generated from the
order flows trader software which you
can add onto a ninjatrader
so before i begin you know just a brief
disclaimer you know trading
involves risk right only risk capital
should be used for trading
and only those with sufficient risk
capital should consider trading
so the first thing i want to talk
understand the about flow and that's why
you're here right you want to understand
you know how can you add order flow to
your analysis
but more importantly how can you make it
easy to read and understand
right you know on the trading floor you
know locals
paid thousands of dollars a month
in leases or hundreds of thousand
dollars for a seat
and why so they can see the order flow
why so they could follow the money
or you always hear that term follow the
money you know when a
trader is on the floor in the old days
you know when there was open outcry
they'd always be watching what the big
brokers are doing because they would
understand who their customers were
what the goldman desk was doing or you
know what the cargill desk was doing
or with solomon
george soros or somebody else you know
or a big company
they would always be watching what those
brokers are doing
you know what are they how are they
active in the market
but when the floors
dried up you know when everything went
electronic
they didn't have that edge anymore you
know a lot of these guys that were
locals on the floor now
are you know the out of work you know
that was their skill set unfortunately
kind of sad but you know they're out
they
they can't read what's going on in the
market because they can't see that slow
now that's where order flow comes in
electronically right because you can
take the data that's coming out from the
exchange
and you can format it in such a way so
you can see
you know the activity of the big traders
that's going on now
while we can't see who is buying or who
is selling like on the floor right you
can see solomon brothers are selling
or goldman sachs buying right you don't
you don't have that transparency
electronically you just see
600 contracts traded at this price 300
traded at this price
right and the other thing is you don't
know if they're getting long or they're
getting short
you sort of have to put it in contact
with what's going on in the market
but what we must focus on is the things
that we can see
we can see the big orders that are being
traded in the market you know when an
order hits the market
and it trades on the exchange it gets
posted right you're going to see that
data come through on your computer
now if you're looking at a normal handle
chart right you just hear your
regular everyday candlestick chart you
know some people think the
greatest card ever because all i can see
is the open i can see the high the lows
closed
i can see the relationship between the
open and the close
and you know i can make a decision from
there well that's all well and good you
know
you know maybe 100 years ago but you
know why
limit yourself okay the volume footprint
chart
yeah it shows you the open high low
close but you can see the volume that's
traded on the bid
volume traded on the offer you can see
where there's buying and balance
people are selling a balance you can see
where traders are defending the price
you can see where traders are being more
aggressive you can see where price is
being exhausted
and so much more that you're not going
to see on just a normal candlestick
chart now most traders
you know when when they hear the term
order flow they think of the dome like
the definite market price ladder
and the difference
between the dome and a volume footprint
chart is the dome just shows you the
working orders
it shows you what's on the bid what's
below the bid the next bid
below that what's on the offer or the
next offer or the next offer
the footprint chart records what's
traded
in the dome and it'll put it
on a chart okay so you can see you know
how much traded on the bid at 39 and a
quarter how much traded
on the offer at 39 39 and a half
or what traded at 39 39 and a quarter
versus 39.39 even now if you look at a
normal candlestick chart you don't even
see the volume right you're just looking
at
where the low is where the open is the
height
and the close now order flow
is really about understanding what the
aggressive traders are doing in the
market
now if you don't understand what
aggressive traders are
think of it this way in the market there
are passive traders and there are
aggressive traders
passive traders are people that are
either trying to
buy on the bid or sell on the offer
they're waiting for price to come to
them
but for a trade to happen someone has to
get aggressive
let's say the market is 33 39
order offer you know 78 on the bid
98 on the offer for a trade to happen
either one of the passive buyers there
at 3939
has to be aggressive and buy one from a
seller at 39
and a quarter or for a
trains happen as well either someone
that's trying to sell it at 39 and a
quarter gotta say you know what i think
there's like
a lower i don't want to miss it you got
to lower their bid to 39.39
they're going to be aggressive so just
remember aggressive sellers sell the
passive buyers
and aggressive buyers buy from passive
sellers
the other way to think of it is you know
you want to buy a car okay
you want to buy a you know the new
corvette
and you go to the dealer you've got one
there for sixty five thousand dollars
i don't wanna pay five thousand i'll
visit thousands well he wants to sell at
sixty five thousand
so you guys no trades gonna happen
unless
one of you is gonna get aggressive the
dealer may think oh gosh you know i got
a truckload of
corvettes coming in next week fine you
know i'll sell it to you at 60 000.
he got aggressively sold it now
if you're going to be the aggressive
buyer thank god you know i really want
this car because you know i gotta
i got a hot date later this week and i
want to impress the girl
so he's not gonna go buy it he's gonna
take 65 000. okay
you become the aggressive buyer so
remember
aggressive buyers buy from passive
sellers
aggressive sellers sell surpasses buyers
now candlesticks charts right they leave
out a lot of information
the footprint chart has that information
you know but if you like your
candlesticks you can keep them because
you can have
on your chart still your candlestick but
you can see
you know the candlestick chart has you
know the volume
which traded on the bid was traded on
the offer where the market is
showing aggressive buying where there's
market exhaustion
the net difference between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers
and you know it's from that information
that you can start analyzing
you know is the aggressive buying
getting weaker or is it getting stronger
is regressive selling getting weaker or
is it getting stronger
now earlier i just explained you know
the volume footprint charts allow you to
see the volume traded on the
volume on the offer and once you have
that information
you know a trader can then take the data
and see the delta
the point of control and the imbalances
and you know and find some good trading
opportunities
so first i'll talk about what is delta
okay so delta is the difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar and if you're looking at a
normal
candlestick chart but you can't see
where traders are being aggressive
you just you know you can't see is there
aggressive buying an aggressive sign you
don't know what's going on
in the aggressive um you know in the
trading
but on a volume equipment chart you can
see where aggressive
traders are in control by watching the
delta now the delta is going to be
along the bottom and what it tells you
right if it's positive delta tells you
aggressive buyers aren't
if it's negative it's going to tell you
that progressive sellers are in control
in that bar so if you see a bar
like here at 12 34 it's got a delta of
minus eight it tells you
you know aggressive scholars were in it
controlled that bar but it's kind of
weak because there's only a difference
of eight is minus eight
so i've got a negative delta where's the
next bar
you can see the delta is uh 75. so it
tells you it's a positive delta
it's green right it's red it's negative
so it tells you aggressive buyers are in
control
so what happens you went from aggressive
sellers into
control to aggressive buyers control
and then the market keeps going up in
the next bar positive delta 379 so
even stronger positive delta so now you
know
aggressive buyers are firmly in control
and you can see the market just drifting
going higher higher higher all on
positive delta
now point of control is the price level
in the bar with the most volume
on a normal bar chart you can't see
point of control
all you can see is the open high locals
and the relation of the open title
but on a volume footprint chart you're
going to see the point of control with
the most volume right and why is that
important is because you know volume
represents or honestly this you know
represents
an area where traders are happy to
transact
it represents value and you can see here
in this purple box i put this
box around here because you can see you
got one two three four five bars
with more or less the point of controls
right around the same level
right so it's indicating to you that
value is being formed right and when you
have value being formed over time what
is that
that's either support or resistance in
this case it's support because it's
coming in
near the low of this move right and
people are happy to trade here you know
people are
buyers are happy to buy you know they're
happy to accumulate a position
those sellers you know are happy to sell
but if the buyers are
are in control right now why because you
can see by the positive delta
even when there are um
negative cells they're still quite small
minus 31 minus
eight right then you can see the buyers
finally take control of the market
after they're done absorbing they start
getting aggressive and the market
starts moving up now imbalances
now this is the third part of you know
sort of the building blocks of order
flow
they occur when you have more aggressive
buyers than aggressive sellers in the
two-way auction
now most of the time the market is
balanced right it's
when the market starts going out of
balance and trading opportunities arrive
so remember what i told you right
aggressive sellers sell the pacifiers
and aggressive buyers
buy some passive sellers but when you
have aggressive buyers
outnumbering the aggressive sellers in
the two-way auction
by a ratio of four to one that's
considered buying a balance so vice
versa
selling and balance if you have more
aggressive sellers
than aggressive buyers in the two-way
auction remember right markets movements
so when you look at the volume footprint
chart at 39.39
even offered at 39 39 and a quarter
and you see oh you know there was um 220
traded at 39
versus just 20 traded at 39 and a
quarter
then you know aggressive sellers are
imbalanced right you have more
you know your next age you have ten
times is more aggressive
um sellers than aggressive buyers and on
a normal
regular candlestick chart again and you
can't see where these imbalances are
occurring
on a flipping chart you can see okay
got aggressive buying coming in here
right as the market starts increasing
higher all these bars going up
that's the address of fires all right
can't see that
this is the same time period on a
candlestick chart
if you're looking at a footprint chart
you can see where the aggressive buyers
are coming in
and so once you understand the
importance of delta quantity control and
imbalances
you can apply them to the market as a
trading to make good trading decisions
and what that means is
you know as the market is trading as
it's unfolding
you're able to make instant decisions
based on what you're reading in the
market
now this is yesterday in the evening
okay so if you remember you know right
after two o'clock we hit our highs
okay so we're at our high we always
anytime you're at a higher low
you always got to be asking what's the
market's going to do next
is it going to keep going higher or is
it going to turn around
and sell off just to be at a low are we
going to make new lows
or are we going to bounce are we going
to go higher so here we're at the high
of the day
yesterday at 57 and a quarter
we got a nice strong positive delta of
660.
right okay well maybe we'll go higher
right because you know we've got
positive delta
closing right up here are high but then
if you watch the next bar
next bar comes in it's a red candle
okay it's got negative delta that's not
a good sign you're at your high of the
day
sellers are also done in control of the
market
what else do you have you've got one two
three imbalances appearing
in the bar again it's also very bearish
right the point of control coming in
lower than the previous bar
so remember if you remember i just said
points to control act as value in a bar
like the most traded prices is a fair
price for that bar so
if all of a sudden the next bar is lower
people are pricing the
market lower right now okay so
the next bar comes in kind of mixed you
know you got negative delta which is
obviously bearish point of control you
know is
one stick higher and yeah you still have
one cell in the balance in there
the bars are doji it opened and closed
at the same price that's kind of neutral
then the next bar again comes in
negative delta got a lower point of
control
now this point of control is the same as
it was two bars ago
so we're sort of putting in value here
but the bars
got an imbalance in it and it's got
negative delta so you know sellers are
slightly in control now
so we're again we're just right up off
our high we got two bars out of three
that are very negative and then another
bar comes in
right we got a higher point of control
but again it's only one stick higher so
now you've got four bars
you take those four points of control
in the bars here you can sort of average
them together to get one price
um you got negative delta minus 284
obviously you got a solid balance
bar goes lower right it's not a good
sign of a market that's looking to
pop around turn around and go higher
that's
starting to shape up as the market
that's getting ready fell off
next bar big strong negative delta minus
got a lower point of control that's just
one
imbalance but you can see how the market
is telling you from two bars ago three
bars ago that
this high is probably going to hold for
no and then the next bar
just an inside bar still got negative
delta point control is
neutral because it's the same price you
don't have any imbalances
kind of a mixed bar then the next bar
again it's another inside bar
you still have negative delta point
control same level
you do have one stone and balance so you
know at this point you gotta be asking
you know is this market
getting ready to go back up or is it
getting ready to fall over
and there's no nothing in here that's
that's remotely bullish
right then you get another bar not an
inside bar it just breaks it by one pick
to the upside
you want to control one stick higher
okay
you got a small delta though it's only
13 right
which isn't you know for the market to
move higher you're going to need strong
positive deltas not a delta
protein and you you need like 300
400 positive deltas these aggressive
buyers are in control
and there's a sign of balance in there
and next bar continues on down right as
expected
right negative delta a lower point of
control
quarter control is coming in lower than
these previous four bars where it's all
sort of aligned
nicely right you got one two three level
one higher
and then boom coming in lower so now
what's happening right we're rejecting
this price at
54 and a quarter and we're putting in a
new value area lower so you can see how
the value areas
are moving lower earlier right off the
high you had four point controls which
more or less you could average those
prices to get one level
here you've got three at the same level
one bar higher so
you have a value here and then you put
in a lower value
now you started putting in a lower value
and again you got a big strong negative
delta minus 500.
the next bar puts in another point of
control at the same level
it's got small negative delta and it's
kind of buying and balance
and you know it's still you know it's
one of those bars that you know as a
trader you
kind of hate seeing because you know it
sort of muddies up the picture a little
bit
and you're short already and you get the
green bar and
sometimes traders like to panic and
they'll cover their shorts now
when they really shouldn't okay then the
next box
strong negative delta you got a lower
point of control
got one binding balance but i wouldn't
worry about that just four against 57
it's not like four against 500 then the
next bar
lower point of control negative delta
still
you have done imbalance so we're
continuing our move down
and then that x bar which everything
changes you know you push lower
push lower about two points lower
than it reverses up near the high
we've got a couple thousand valves in
there
you got a big negative delta but this
bar
some of my advanced lectures that i've
done on
posted up on youtube i talked about this
type of bar on how this is
a reversal bar why you got negative
delta
and it's really large because you've got
supportive lines
here so this is designed to finally get
out of
this trade that you've been short from
you know the 60-60 area down in
three years
this is the regular candlestick chart
right
to me you know looking at a candlestick
chart
it's not obvious at all you mean you can
make arguments for
selling up here at the high oh you know
you got these big red candles that are
you know kind of thick guys when they're
right you know they wave their arms
around
the trailer point they're wrong they're
all quiet
okay so you know
there's a lot of bearish candles on this
way up here
okay so you know don't
don't don't feel shame if you look at a
canvas click start sometimes
you can't figure out what's going on but
when you look at an oracle card it
really starts to
fall into place you can see by watching
delta point of control and then
balancing to understand what's going on
in the market
right now on a bar by bar basis but
wouldn't it be better
right if you have software that would
highlight that to the real time
order flow nuances that you could trade
around it's going to make workflow
trading
a lot easier and that's that was my
whole
point of creating my software years ago
in fact you know i created my software
for my own use
actually didn't create it to become a
group you know a software vendor
and i was training for myself and you
know sharing it with other traders and
they're like hey you know what you don't
realize what you got here
help a lot of people so you know that's
why eventually i started up
the workflows.com so what i want to talk
about now is this point to control
i want to go a little bit deeper into
some of these topics so
talk about points of control every bar
has a point of control
however depending on market structure
and volume involved
a point of control can show you market
generated or resistant
as it happens okay so
for example again you mean yesterday
right everything i was showing these
from yesterday
on a regular candlestick chart
what can you see oh yeah i was made and
came off
and hit another you know looked like it
was coming back up and pulled off
but rather you should be asking you know
what you don't you know what a lot of
traders will do is look at after the
fact
see the high poking up here at uh 53 and
a half
63 course oh well that was resistant
i'll just
make that statement right without
anything to back it up
but actually i'll show you where the
resistance came in
in the order flow that was very clear
okay so this is the footprint chart and
again they ask you
can you see the resistance some advanced
order flow traders will see it right
away
but for others it's
not easy to see but there it is right
where the arrow is
the purple box this was one of the
things that i wanted in my software this
is a
song type
i specifically told my programmer you
know i want to see these what i call
prominent point controls these point of
controls
that matter in the market that are going
to act as support or resistance and we
want to highlight them
in a different color but again you know
if you're just looking at a normal
footprint chart you're not going to see
it if you're looking at a normal bar
chart handles hits heart you're not
going to see it
but it's coming in right in here
right here in this purple box
put a cap on the market for moving
higher
and see how you know over the next five
minutes it makes a nice methodical move
down
okay so here's i'll show you a bunch of
different charts now i'm gonna show you
different charts don't think you have to
have
all these different charts open the
reason i'm showing you different charts
because you know everybody trades
differently right we all don't look at a
one minute chart we all don't look at a
5 000 bonding chart or a
four range chart so however what type of
chart you're looking at those same
things apply in the order flow whether
you're looking at a 5 000 volume
chart a five minute chart you know a 30
second chart
whatever you're going to still look for
the same thing so you can see here's the
prominent point of control
at the swing low where does it rally up
to another prominent port of control
where the market
hits the resistance area and just goes
sideways
there's a thousand tick chart in the
e-menu
see the two prominent point of controls
there putting a cap on the market from
moving higher there's an eight range
chart
now you can see that's the double top
you can see you have the probably 40
controls acting as resistance
on the move down right for the market to
move down it just doesn't always happen
on aggressive selling people selling the
market lower lower lower
the big traders are going to be offering
it out and they're going to be
putting a cap on the market just as you
know on a move
up the big traders are going to be
offering
support in the market you know they're
going to help bid the market
up and what you want to do is you know
once you recognize that you're going to
trade in that direction
that's why i talked about you know going
with what the big traders are doing
so every time you know you pop up
through resistance level
you want to get short if you're not
already short
here's gold right it's a one minute
chart yesterday boom right off that
lowest uh
28 27 80.
at 20 28 big prominent point of control
just sticking out right there
and over the next again over the next 10
minutes market
you know put in a five dollar rally
there's bonds like four range charts you
can see putting in these
nice um primary point controls here as
support for the market market rallies up
rallies up through resistance area
market comes off where you come off to
now when you came off you didn't have
the you didn't see the prominent point
of control but we're coming off right
through those same levels
those were your supports earlier it came
off you keep rallied up and you start
coming off and where do you come off
you gotta stop at support
crude oil right see right just
off the high of the day you got
resistant selling coming in
market comes off rallies up a little bit
comes back off
right rally again boom get another
resistance selling another prominent
point of control
in the market as the market spells off
to where down here we got two prominent
point of controls acting that support
and this is happening in the market
in real time
you can see this happening in real time
and trade it you know you're not
saying oh yeah there's resistance up
here at 42
30 and you know by the time you you're
trading it
it's already trading 42 i don't know you
can see that instantly you know as it's
happening
oh hey this is resistance at 42 um
30. i'm trying to sell 25 so it comes
back up to
25 26. you're short boom like it sells
off
down below 42 where you hit the support
areas down here at 41.88
down here founder point control products
on control
market comes up okay yeah i've got my
business here about 41.90
so as you can see some point controls
are more important than others
and having software that shows you point
of control
that matter will put you ahead of other
traders who can't differentiate one
point of control from another
and still put your head to those traders
who are not even looking at 20 control
at all now what i'll talk about is
imbalances
okay and buying a balance like i said
earlier occurs when in the two-way
option when there are more aggressive
buyers than sellers by a certain ratio
usually four to one
assigned a balance with the offices it's
still a two-way auction but when you
have more aggressive sellers than
aggressive buyers
by a certain ratio again usually four to
one now this four to one
is not set in stone some people use
three to one some people use ten to one
you could adjust it anywhere i know some
people use six for one
i use four to one in some cases i use
three to one but generally i use four to
one
so how does the trader use imbalances to
their advantage well the first place to
look
is their bar handle moving up green
candle and are they're buying the
balances
so how many cans are moving down there's
a red candle
are there sauna balances so how many so
again yesterday's high in the fcc
right right after we hit that high you
can see that bar has three
on about right that's not a good sign
for a market that wants to go higher
right what do you see
you know if you're looking at the oracle
card you see aggressive sellers
clearly in control of their farm
now this is crude oil right you can see
as the market moves lower
what do you see you see the aggressive
sellers right so as the markets
move up you see aggressive buyers right
in the form of buying development
and as the market moves down you see
aggressive sellers in the form of
non imbalances right here's the market
moving up you see
all these little buying imbalances early
right before the big move up
just started now most order for traders
understand what imbalances are
and why they occur the next step is to
apply this market now stack imbalances
how most traders apply imbalance and
what a stacked imbalance is
is this just it's a bar that has three
or more
either bind imbalances or stack binding
valves or three or more sauna balances
for effects on imbalance
and tech neatly on top of each other at
each price level
um over three consecutive price levels
so i could see the stack buying a
balance down here
at 31 you know 31 and a quarter there's
another one and 31 and a half there's
another minor balance it says on
the sauna balance you got one at 33 33
32 and three quarters and 32 and a half
right they're all neatly stacked on top
of each other and that's all
you know that's nice it's pretty looking
on a chart
you know you could draw zones out and
you know try to play the pullbacks into
them
for good entry to get short would get
long for buying them down
you know optically they're pretty okay
but sometimes
by the time that you see them the market
is already put in a big move
because sometimes when they appear it's
a bit of foam all right traders are
missed the move
and like i tell a lot of people
in my weekly classes you know there are
two problems with dealing with
imbalances
if you just wait for stack and balances
to occur and trade them sometimes we're
waiting for a long time
because you're going to make a lot of
great training opportunities in the
meantime
and some bars have imbalances some bars
don't
the parts that have imbalances or which
imbalances matter
and some bars that have no imbalances
okay some buyers may have one
some bars may have two some bars may
have three or more
what bar do you think has the potential
to move the most
a bar with one imbalance one balance no
one balances or a bar
three or more in balance well obviously
the answer is a bar with three or more
imbalances
but not necessarily stats right
i said you know a lot of traders have
spent a lot of time looking for that
stacking balance that never comes
so bars are three or more imbalances
okay so you could see a nice stacked
imbalance here
as you're breaking through this low of
the day here this red line is below
33.35 yeah a nice stacked selling
imbalance here
that's great the market continues to
move all the way down to 29 before
reversing that value back up
but
look at the bar two bars earlier it's
got four
dollar bells okay and that's coming in
you know two points higher than the
stacked on the ballot would you rather
have two extra points in your move then
on the way back
up do you see any stack fine imbalances
no there is none
but you see one bar with three
imbalances another bar with three
imbalances without a bar with four
imbalance
right do you think this information is
useful for you of course it is
the order close trader software will put
a box around
the bars with multiple filing the
balance three or more imbalances
either dollar balances in the down bars
for buying balances from the red cars
i just like talked about letting the
software do the work for you and again
you know
if you're not using software that's
going to highlight this
you may not see that right away by the
time you see it you may have missed the
opportunity
right and you know trading is an
opportunistic
endeavor you got to take advantage of
this stuff
as soon as it happens right that's where
your edge is by
getting in on trades that other people
are completely misuse
for whatever reason okay so again here
look for the imbalances
okay so i just talked about some
dominant points of control on how
important they were did you know that
these bars also have
multiple spelling imbalances in there
it's telling you you know there's
resistance there's
resistance in the market with control
and there's aggressive spelling
you know honestly we live in a great
time for traders computers are
affordable
easy to open a training account markets
create around the clock so it doesn't
matter if you're
working during the day you come home at
night you trade
e-mini and now they have micro contracts
that you can trade that have
very low margin you know back in the
gosh 20 years 20 years ago you know to
open a training account
but to get a low commission rate the low
was considered
you know ten dollars a size or even
before that back in the 90s 20
side you know which is 40 a round turn
you know was considered discount already
and you know
now we're living in places where they
have day trade margins so
you know literally there's brokers out
there i don't got not tempting any
brokers but there are brokers out there
that you can trade you can open a
futures account with
300 400 and trade the micro contract
with 50 margins um you know it's a great
way to get started
you know you don't have to go all in and
you know trade full margin you know if
you're
opening a small account with a few
hundred dollars just in one micro you
don't need to
get fifty dollars margin you don't need
to trade
um you know ten contracts on the five
months just pick one you know get used
to the market
great opportunity to get started at low
cost like i said you know it's a great
time for traders
now here's gold right can you see
what's happening in the market right
yeah you can see the deck buying
development as the market is going
up okay that's great then it hits this
point here at 29
and then it just falls off 29 down to
25.
okay but if you're using software that's
going to highlight things for you
right you see put the arrows here where
the multiple buy-in balances are and
multiple
balances are even up here the prominent
point of control
let the software highlight all that
information to you boom
see it's got the pink box around it it's
got the
prominent point of control the bearish
pawn point control up here
followed by a bar with multiple sauna
balances and again
now you need to be getting short in here
at 28
well before it breaks down here at 26.
you know most traders are going to see
this move
they're not going to know right away to
get short unless they're looking at the
overflow
obviously you can see the delta is all
negative up here but this is last night
just after 10 o'clock it just shows you
you know like i was saying you know it's
a great time for traders because there's
liquidity around the clock you can trade
a lot of these markets
in the evening time even if you're
working and again you don't have to be
going all in and you know trading at
full margin you know you open accounts
only three thousand dollars just create
one lot
simple on a normal bar chart
right you're not going to necessarily
see that you'll know there's
only on the fitness chart you're going
to know there's resistance
and you're going to know there's not a
balance by watching the order flow
right you know you know some kind of
sometimes
well you know you got that type of
candlestick here well you have a similar
one there
they had a lot of bullish candles on the
way up now that's the other here uh
there
that's an argument that it's often had
after the fact you know but as a trader
but you want to be also you want to be
alerted yeah i got resistance up here
based on the order flow
i've got aggressive spelling based on
the imbalances
in the order flow i've got negative
delta
and tell me sellers are in control we
just made it high
but there's negative delta right you
think the market's gonna go any higher
no no you're gonna need aggressive
buying for the market to go higher
instead you're seeing
the opposite you're seeing resistance
selling seeing aggressive spelling
you're seeing each bar being in control
by sellers
that's not a recipe for a market to go
higher that's the recipe for the market
to go lower
all right so you know hopefully by now
you can understand you know order flow
is a great tool for traders to
understand what's happening in the
market and honestly there's so much more
to cover for example i didn't even talk
about these little
red arrows on top of bars read arrows
um these are bullish embarrassed
instances in the order flow
to either get you into trade or if
you're in a trade
keep you in winning trades longer you
know that's where real benefit is for
many traders
is being
not being able to manage a trade and
that's something that goes
you know sort of hand in hand you know
everybody says you got to cut your
losses short and let your winners run
but they'll actually tell you how to do
it when you read the order flow
you can see whether the order flow
that's happening after you're in a trade
is bullish or bearish so if you're
bullish and also you see a bunch of
bearish order flow
that's not a good sign right so you got
two choices one
you could let the market just go stop
you out or two
you can pull the plug on the tray get
out early now if you're long
and you have bullish orderful following
after you get
into the trade that's good you can let
the trade run
longer like that's how you let your
winners run
and cut your losers short by managing
the trades
you don't let your winners run and you
lose your short by
throwing in at arbitrary stop and take
profit
based on an average over 20 trades
you watch it by what's happening in the
market you know it's
for a trade to become profitable you
need the order flow
that follows once you get into that
trade go in your direction if it's not
going in your direction
trade is going to struggle to turn a
profit
now i cover these topics such as you
know what all these little
green and red arrows mean i'm going to
generate from my software
and numbers above and below the bars
for in my weekly group training session
for users
which i'll tell you about more of that
in a minute but hopefully by now
you should start putting together the
different parts of order flow
and you can see the markets make sense
waterfall analysis provides the trader
advanced information they need to gain
so i said you got to have an edge in the
market and then they don't tell you how
to get an edge
oracle gives you an edge allows you to
see and understand what's happening in
the market
that other traders just don't see so
hopefully you can see how powerful
workflow now
remember don't over complicate trading
people like to overcomplicate trading
some reason you know they i gotta throw
ten indicators up on my chart now i
gotta go five
but okay what's your best indicator you
know read what's happening in the market
right in front of you
so if you found this helpful you're
gonna like my wonderful sprayer 2.0
software package which makes the
announcement easy
and there's two ways you can go about
becoming a successful trader
with workflow one you can try and learn
order flow on your own
it's gonna take you years by looking at
a screen and trying to figure out the
workflow you know i spent 25 years
trading okay it
doesn't it's not something that comes
instantly for some people it does you
know
people are autistic or you know can pick
things up
really quick and more importantly you
don't want to waste years
and money trying to learn it right
second way is get the education software
from a trader who's successfully traded
order flow
at the highest level for decades it
keeps the massive trading losses
get the wasted time you know sort of go
to the front of the line
remember order flow is the most current
information available from the trader
and it's not some indicator it's the
market right
order flow is not based on pivot levels
it's not fibonacci it's not based on
elliott waves not based on that
etc it's not based on
workflow is what's trading on the bid
and what's trading on the offer
basically it is the market you're
trading the market right you're not
trading the indicator you're creating
the market
so the order flows trader 2.0 uh telling
you about earlier
it runs on ninjatrader 8. it'll run on
the free version of ninjatrader 8 so if
you're using a
broker's trading platform you can
download the free version administrator
eight and load up my software on it
and it'll run there you just obviously
you're gonna need paper data
and what it is it's a volume footprint
chart with seven pre-programmed order
flow
indicators template so your chart could
look just like mine
i don't spend hours trying to figure it
out normally i sell it for
899 but i realize you know having order
full software is one thing
the next thing is to know how to use it
i don't just give you the software and
send you on your way
try and figure it out no i provide a lot
of education on how to play with order
flow
now each week tuesday so i have one
tonight i do a private live group
training session just for users
can attend 340. there's over 80 80
reporting now
some gurus you know like to charge extra
for this i give you for free i mean why
charge you extra for training
on how to you know how to use the
software how to read the market
you know that should be free you know
it's ongoing i got guys that bought
myself for five years ago
that still attend the session you know
they still love you know
sometimes i i'm late to sending out the
invite for the
training session then people hit me up
hey i have a session
and i you know it's amazing
you know the best traders are the
traders that want to learn
i also give you access to my oracle's
trading course which i normally felt for
297. you'll get access to that for free
as well as my inner circle video series
normally i sell this to 497 and what it
is it's a collection of
56 advanced videos on advanced articles
tricks
okay tricks but nuances tips and
analysis
you can get it for free each video is
about an hour long
so you know 8.99 for the software 297
the oracle training course the inner
circle's another 4.97
weekly group training i don't know put a
price on it again you know some people
have been attending that for years
so that i can't even put a price on
think of it like this right you've never
been to disneyland or losing a park
i mean you got your car you walked oh my
god look at that line
what i want to do is take you to the
front of the line all these other
traders trying to learn how to try to
don't want to you know fast track it
and what i will also give you is access
to my order flow
playbook which is normally two hundred
ninety seven dollars and we give that to
you also for free
but you're pushing close to two thousand
dollars right
possibly more with the live group
training
but again you know if you're unsure you
know it's what other people are saying
you know mike your order flow software
is remarkably helpful
now what's happening in the market like
for example losing control of the market
on a very specific time and who's
staying
here as well you know other traders say
you give a really fresh insane error in
the field very impressive very rare
mike's experience and explanation makes
it click
so now if you're interested go to
orderflows.com
off two because you know we all want to
be successful but to become successful
whether it's in training or any other
line of work to and it you've got to
figure out how you're going to get from
point a to point b so for a one-time
payment
for one-time payment of just 675 you're
going to
be able to get the order flows trader
2.0
so go to oracle.com you know there's no
other monthly payments
oh you know i got you know you got to
pay this me
you know every year or something no it's
just a one-time payment a yearly fee
that's it
so what you're going to do after you go
to off order close dot com slash office
and i'll take you to the stage just
scroll down to the bottom of the page
okay so you'll see the button because
by now i want this right now you want to
get started
make it a paypal i don't process your
card i don't want any of your
information anything like that
third-party processor you know
everybody's familiar with paypal i think
but again if you don't have a paypal
account just say pay with a debit card
and your credit card here and it will
take you still within paypal
now if you want my book the order flows
book
trading order flow go to
orderflows.combook.html
you'll need to enter your name and email
address after you do that hit submit
okay then it'll take you directly to the
download page with the pdf so you can
um save it to your computer you can save
it to your
smartphone you can save it to your
tablet print it out
you know read it over the weekend it's a
nice book
you know and this is my way of giving
back to the trading community
again you gotta get started some sooner
or later
right so act now go to order flows.com
offu.html you know that
it's strange but like there's people
that i've
communicated with that you know over the
last couple of years
tell me yeah i wanna start trading and
it never gets started you know i'm just
like you know you gotta get started
sometimes you know it's
something to want to do something as
opposed to doing it right you gotta
take action you know i remember i used
to work with this guy just perfect
example
and they kept telling me oh this girl i
want to ask out
you know girl i want to ask her out like
that for a week i'm like dude
finally do something ask her out you
know and
he did and you know a year later they
got married you know like man
you spend all that time you know oh
she's got to be interested you know
you don't know unless you start doing it
you don't know if you're going to be
good at trading unless you start trading
and
yeah i i want to have a caveat you know
trading is not for everybody
um you know i i don't want you to have
to come in here with high hopes thinking
that
oh this is you know the holy grail no
trading takes work
and you gotta want to be able to put in
the work
and get going so you know
it's not an easy journey so
you're going to want to get started
sooner or later so i'm just going to
take a look at these as any questions
here real quick you know there's not
really any questions but you know
one of the questions that i get
is you know it doesn't work on stocks
and does it work on forex well
the thing with 4x right is that
the exchanges are not centralized right
like on cme
and cbot right where the human body
those are exchanges proper extreme and
every trade that goes through
is registered and everyone in the world
can see that that they traded now
on forex right you got like you have a
lot of brokers
and what they have is white label
products from bank and
basically it's the bank giving you
basically giving you you know
their vested offer so the data you're
going to see on your screen is different
from what you guys see
being traded
so it does work as 4x but you know you
can trade
on a cme forex contract um the euro
currency you've got some dan burgess
column
and really quick on stocks yeah your
best trading
most liquid stocks obviously you know
bank stocks apple
and google netflix facebook
but they trade a lot of volume and
remember you're analyzing
volume now one other question what time
frame do you
trade typically using your software well
oil order flow
is based on what's happening right now
so
if you're trading a 30 minute chart
but you're reading order flow from 30
minutes ago an hour ago it's not going
to be any useful
for you honestly it's best to trade
order flow on shorter time frames you
know
one minute cars even range page charts
as you're watching how the market moves
from fights to price
um you know personally me personally i
don't go over five minutes
i use one minute chart i use 30 second
chart
and in some cases and i do go a little
bit shorter
um you know when i trade nasdaq i will
go down
no i don't have a trade room anymore um
it's just
not possible for me time-wise to do and
you know it's one thing to
have a trade room and explain trades
there's nothing to actually be trading
and just i just don't do it anymore i
used to do it a few years ago i don't do
it anymore
i've got three kids now and with the
stay at home
order and it looks like the school year
is going to be we're going to be staying
at home again
um it's just not possible to have a
trading room hard enough for me to get
into
the time to do the trade with the kids
running around
they're having a trading room not but
you know i have the weekly group
training session so
you know i talk about things that i've
seen in the order flow
you know over the last week or so
anything interesting
and this is another question is this a
standalone way of trading
nothing else is required well again you
know order flow is a tool
it's about reading what's happening in
the market i know some people that added
order flow because they already
have a way they have their own
way of drawing order resistance in the
market
or areas where they think the market's
going to react and they want to know
what's happening in
the order flow so can you use the
standalone yeah i use a standalone
but again there's other people that have
incorporated into
their own method of training
so anyway on that note i've kept you
guys here for about an hour
and you know i don't i appreciate your
time i know we're all busy
these days especially you know those
that have kids in the house and trying
to juggle
um everything it's a big thing to ask so
i'll end it there yeah if you got any
questions
you could just email me mike
orderflows.com
or you know i suggest you know get
started read the book download the book
it's
orderflows.combook.html
where is it here you know that's a great
way to get started go to my youtube page
okay i've got a lot of videos on there
got over 250 videos
it's also a great resource to get
started you know if you want to know
more about order flow and you know
is it something that suits you okay and
again
the best thing to do is just get started
kathy i'll
throw it back to you and that will be it
thanks everybody
hi everyone wanna thank you for coming
out to online trader central tonight
kind thanks goes to our host
mike at order flows.com i've been
posting all the information how you get
the free ebook how you get hold of him
after we're done
and we really appreciate your time and
attention here today we know that time
is one of those commodities or just not
trading on the internet
and you can never get